dove c'è la volontà c'è un modo una
strada anche se visto un ostacoli una
strada che in questa splendida cornice
mi vien da pensare come l'acqua l'acqua
un elemento vitale un elemento che per
me significa anche digitale proprio per
la sua fluidità ed adattabilità è stato
un argomento che abbiamo toccato
tantissimo negli ultimi anni soprattutto
quest'estate da un lato per la sua forte
assenza dall'altro per la sua forte
necessità e per chi come me è nata in
una città di mare Beh l'acqua è un
elemento veramente Vitale me lo sono
promessa starei sempre stata guidata da
questo elemento e starei sempre
ritornata al mare in fin dei conti
Ognuno di noi ha un fiume dentro e il
mio fiume dentro mi ha permesso di
ostacoli di recuperare ogni ostacolo per
arrivare in fin dei conti per più della
metà stiamo fatti d'acqua mi sono
costruita proprio sull'acqua la mia
isola il mio mondo quello di kiki così
mi facevo particolare dove costruivo i
miei sogni e i miei obiettivi chi sta
sta anche voi avete un posto un luogo
un'isola dove costruite sogni e
obiettivi E qual è l'elemento che lo
caratterizza per alcuni di voi
Probabilmente la terra come le rocce di
questa montagna l'aria il fuoco l'etere
o l'acqua stessa L'importante è cercare
di Far coincidere sogni ed obiettivi e
quello che ho cercato di fare sull'isola
di kiki è stato proprio questo solamente
con il tempo ho capito però che c'è una
sottile differenza Il potere della
realizzazione da un lato le
improbabilità dei sogni e dall'altro la
concretezza degli obiettivi ma c'è un
modo per unire due mondi quello di
sfondare le proprie paure di uscire
dalla propria comfort zone e farlo e
provarlo In fin dei conti stessi può
sognare si può realizzare
e se ognuno di voi o di ognuno di noi ha
una vocina al proprio interno che dice
Tu non puoi farlo Beh cominciamo a farlo
ancora più forte e quella vocina verrà
sedata o se qualcuno vi dirà tu non sei
in grado di farlo Beh sarà proprio
quella persona a mostrare i propri
limiti ma non i vostri perché è
possibile superare i limiti proprio
partendo dai propri superpoteri ognuno
di noi ce li ha Vi ricordate quando da
piccoli chiudevamo Gli occhi giravamo
forti su noi stessi e sognavamo di
essere un supereroe di averli
superpoteri per superare questi limiti
il mio
mio padre probabilmente come per tanti
di voi i suoi superpoteri Beh il potere
dell'ascolto attivo mi sapeva dare
fiducia ma mi dava anche molta
responsabilità e poi
e qui partiamo dal Digital all'analogico
mi ha regalato questo piccolo libro me
lo sono portata dietro per 40 anni
Probabilmente perché piccole stagno una
mano è stato ancora più facile seconda
storia di un topo chiuso in un libro e
la storia di un topolino che scappa
dalle proprie paure e si rifugia
all'interno di questo libro all'interno
di queste pagine trova la sua comfort
zone e vi sta particolarmente bene
solamente che dopo poco comincia a
capire di avere una necessità di andare
oltre a questi limiti delle pagine e
comincia a rosicchiare queste pagine
comincia ad entrare l'acqua una
sensazione piacevolissima delle belle
gocce fresche ha la necessità di
abbattere la quarta parete di unire due
mondi e più comincia e continua a
superare questi limiti e più L'acqua
continua ad entrare fortissima
all'interno di queste pagine
Beh il topolino ha pochissimo tempo per
lavorare una strategia per fronteggiare
questa acqua dirompente prende un
angolino di questa piccola pagina
mordicchiato con i suoi dentini e
costruisce una propria barchetta vi
posso assicurare che su questo libricino
l'ultima immagine ha un potere votivo
fortissimo me lo sono portata dietro
tutta la vita vedere questo topolino che
esce da questo libro sulla sua barchetta
a stampare le onde dell'oceano guardando
l'orizzonte mi ha fatto capire che tutto
è possibile ognuno di noi può trovare il
suo super potere superare la propria
comfort zone ed arrivare oltre i propri
limiti
[Applauso]
chi sta Se ognuno di voi ha già trovato
il proprio super power alzate le mani Se
pensate di averlo trovato
la Vedo qualcuna molto timida
Chi non l'ha alzata è semplicemente
perché non l'ha ancora trovato ognuno di
noi ce l'ha io la Alzo il mio potere
quello di essere un pensatore creativo
di utilizzare l'emisfero destro la mia
parte diciamo più intuitiva quello di
saper unire intuito dato dall'esperienza
e il mio gatto feeling quella cosa di
pancia che postiamo trovare con
l'obiettivo proprio di abbattere questa
quarta parete mi piace vedere le cose
dall'inizio alla fine unire tutti i
puntini e all'interno di questo mondo di
questo ecosistema A volte riesco anche
ad anticipare alcuni eventi alcuni Trend
però per la paura di non essere capita e
per la voglia di essere accettata ho
sempre lavorato su un qualche cosa che
sapevo essere mio su qualcosa su cui ero
brava per sentirmi dire stai brava
quante volte vi siete vi siete detti
Sono stato bravo
Io ho iniziato a farlo
sei stata brava con una forte pacca
sulla spalla Credetemi ha un potere
fortissimo liberatorio così come ha
iniziato a dirmi grazie grazie per tutte
le volte che sono riuscita a fare
qualcosa per tutte le volte che non ci
sono riuscita ma che continuerò a farlo
la prima volta che ho provato a superare
il mio limite a uscire dalla mia comfort
zone me lo ricordo ancora ero al liceo
mi ero incaponita nel voler mettere in
piedi un ipertesto i più giovani
probabilmente non sanno neanche che
cos'è un ipertesto ma era gli algori del
digitale era un insieme di informazioni
codici non scontato dato da vari
elementi foto musica testi Uniti da
delle dei percorsi da delle connessioni
logiche inaspettate
me lo ricordo ancora
sono entrata all'interno del mio liceo e
i professori hanno iniziato a cantare a
squarciagola e Another Brick in The Wall
dei Pink Floyd Ero partita da un punto
di vista non convenzionale parlavo dal
crollo del muro di Berlino 10 anni dopo
ero riuscita ad abbattere la quarta
parete la mia esperienza l'avevo fatta
vivere anche i professori che erano
entrati con me all'interno del mio mondo
creativo ero riuscita a collegare tutte
le materie dal graffitismo di chi
staring al muro delle nostre menti per
arrivare anche le poesie della
letteratura tedesca gli avevo spiazzati
ed ecco quello che ho capito Bisogna
lavorare sul proprio Human Power sul
proprio Human Factor interno e farlo
scorrere come l'acqua
però questo Human Power questo fiume va
alimentato fortissimo non basta superare
un limite e uscire un'unica volta dalla
comfort zone è necessario continuare a
farlo come l'acqua come la goccia Scava
la pietra ma non per la sua forza bensì
per la sua costanza e così con la mia
Costanza ho deciso di lasciare la mia
piccola città di mare da dove ero andata
e sono andata in giro per il mondo come
molti di voi hanno fatto ho iniziato a
superare i miei limiti a conquistare i
miei obiettivi ma man mano che
raggiungevo questi obiettivi cominciavo
a ricostruire quella quarta parete
continuavo e cominciavo a richiudermi su
me stessa perché perché avevo superato
troppo i miei limiti umani così molti
viaggi dopo tanti fusi orari tante
riunioni tante Call mi sono richiuse su
me stessa e ho capito una grande una
grande cosa A volte quando si è dato
troppo bisogna anche fermarsi e lasciare
andare le cose come un fiume
in grado di cambiare direzione quando il
vostro corpo quando il vostro fisico ve
lo chiede mi piace parlare oggi di
limiti umani la sostenibilità dei nostri
limiti credo sia una parte fondamentale
nelle aziende Nel digitale pochi ancora
l'hanno capito parlare oggi di super
manager guru del digitale poco importa
sono dei solisti la vera differenza la
farà il pensiero intuitivo quello
collettivo e fondamentale orchestrare la
complessità e non governare o dirigere
un manager oggi non può più decidere
l'opzione a o l'opzione B c'è il
digitale c'è la tecnologia c'è la
robotica l'artificial intelligence il
metaverso quello che deve fare oggi un
manager e sviluppare la propria capacità
intuitiva l'intuitive thinking e far
lavorare assieme le persone
una grande obeia la grande stanza della
condivisione starebbe bello metterla al
posto della Stanza dei Bottoni dei
superpoteri dei super manager A volte mi
chiedo se il digitale rappresenti più
dei limiti piuttosto che delle
possibilità ne abbiamo parlato anche in
apertura non so quanti di voi sanno che
ogni minuto Instagram condivide più di
407.000 post degli utenti su Google ci
sono più di 3 milioni e mezzo di
ricerche ogni minuto su Tik Tok più di
160 milioni di video visti ogni minuto
se queste piattaforme vengono
moltiplicate per le n per gli n Giant
che ci sono immaginate quante
informazioni oggi un manager Nel
digitale si trova a dover gestire
impossibile non umano Ma per questo ci
sarà l'intelligenza artificiale quello
chi manager staranno chiamati a fare
superare i propri limiti con l'intuiti
thinking nella stanza dei bottoni che
diventerà un obeia andare a pensare
assieme imparare assieme interagire
insieme
[Applauso]
mi sento molto fortunata per aver capito
i miei limiti ho deciso di abbandonare
modelli di leadership che non mi non mi
appartengono Ho provato a lavorare sul
mio modello di leadership quello basato
sul Human Factor E questo che insegno le
persone che lavorano con me guardare
sempre le cose da un punto di vista
differente o la fortuna di aver
abbracciato i miei sogni con i miei
obiettivi lavoro Nel digitale il web per
me è un po' come il mio primipertesto il
primo amore l'inizio della tecnologia
per me un Canvas bianco su cui poter
disegnare esperienze emozioni mettere in
contatto brand e consumatori raggiungo
diverse persone con diversi toni di voce
diversi formati diversi contenuti che
cambiano ogni giorno ho capito che
bisogna essere come l'acqua ma loro
promessa quando c'è una volontà c'è un
modo una strada per farlo ed essere come
l'acqua significa poter seguire il
proprio fiume interno il proprio Human
Factor metterlo a fattor comune a
disposizione della propria Community sta
per cambiare aggirare i propri ostacoli
e sapersi anche fermare Se necessario
per seguire il proprio ritmo evitiamo
però di incorrere in periodi disticità o
di aridità come quello che stiamo
vivendo a livello planetario e grazie
alla collettività questo potrà essere
superato non possiamo tornare indietro e
non postiamo cambiare l'inizio ma
possiamo vivere nel presente e guardare
il futuro come il Topolino della seconda
storia di un topo chiuso in un libro fa
sulla sua barchetta guardare l'infinito
e mi piacerebbe che tutti quanti ci
dicessimo stiamo stati bravi questo per
me è Limitless Grazie
[Applauso]